Democrats taking their impeachment probe
public shifty shift announcing Congress
will hold open hearings next week
finally it comes after he dumped a new
transcript from the testimony of top
diplomat in Ukraine bill tailor ship
claiming this new phase of the
investigation will damage the president
those open hearings will be an
opportunity for the American people to
evaluate the witnesses for themselves to
make their own determinations about the
credibility of the witnesses but also to
learn firsthand about the facts of the
president's misconduct okay one I know
you love polls so I brought a poll for
you thank you this is morning consult
very accurate and it says support for
impeachment falls as inquiry moves to a
new phase and people don't approve of
the Democrats handling of impeachment
your thoughts well I did I I haven't
seen that one but I heard about it and
of course you got to put in the context
which is that there's been in the last
two months continual rise and supports
largely plateaued at this juncture as we
go towards the public phase of this
hearing okay I think that the question
about Bill Taylor is interesting because
Taylor is a West Point grad a veteran
someone who was selected almost
handpicked by Secretary of State Pompeo
to serve in the Trump administration so
efforts to undermine him to say oh you
know what he's a never Trump er he's a
bad guy I think it's very difficult and
so therefore his testimony is going to
have impact and then I think the
secondary argument on this one jesse is
but he wasn't on the call but then you
hear from others who were on the call
and you have others saying pretty much
the same thing okay so it's just like
the attack on the whistleblower which
been going on and of course all of the
whistleblowers had been corroborated but
Trump and his guys are saying okay what
about the whistleblower like it's
distracting Kennedy I felt like the
Democrats had the American people's
attention for a second and then they
totally lost it and now no one cares
about this Taylor Volcker Sandlin that's
not breaking through it's not because
you don't have the big thing yet and if
you have a bunch of little things people
lose track of names they lose track of
conversations they lose track of
timelines and that
is the fault of the Democrats who
stretched this out in the wrong way and
they really should have waited until
there was this formal impeachment
inquiry resolution so we can have all of
this in the open but the problem is a
lot of these people have already
testified and so their statements are a
known quantity so now all you're going
to have are Republicans and Democrats
acting like show ponies just trying to
out jazz hands each other to play gotcha
with the various witnesses and I don't
think we've gotten there yet and you
know what it reminds me of in terms of
polls medicare-for-all because if you
ask people should we insure everybody
they go absolutely we should we should
insure everybody and it's the same thing
if the president did something bad
should he be impeached absolutely he
should be impeached and he should be
removed if he did something bad but if
he did something bad is the part where
you have to pay for it no one wants to
pay for Medicare for all and no one has
been shown that what he has done so far
is absolutely 100% impeachable and it
has to rot bribe bribery
Rudy Giuliani has gone rogue okay I
understand it's a lot here let's see
Regan Greg um if you're doing all this
stuff in shifty shifts creepy little
dark basement under the Capitol I think
Americans were focused for a second then
they started thinking about football and
and what's going on this weekend I think
it's over now I love these open Harry's
because it's an opportunity as Shifa
said to see how petty the Democrats are
and what thin gruel they're playing with
the media has replaced the Ukraine or
replaced Russia with the Ukraine yet the
public isn't keen on it anymore if you
look at the left-wing media they aren't
getting that same bump that they got
from the rush of stuff and it's because
it's like they're getting back together
with someone who cheated on them that's
the Ukraine feel because they got burned
on Russia Russia they put all their
hearts into Russia and it fell apart
they can't do it again with Ukraine
because they're now beginning to see
that this is a fable based on opinions
based on other opinions it's all about
if right the concern angle in which
you're concerned about something that
might happen but doesn't or hasn't looks
like if Donald track to one sentence if
Donald Trump shot somebody on Fifth
Avenue
would he get away with it that has never
happened but that but that question
question informs there's a strategy what
I would call the concerned strategy
where they they try to avoid the
concrete achievements of Trump and
replace with hypothetical hysterics like
what if he does this what if he lied
what if this was this and also the media
wants the public to think that quid pro
quo is like the plague actually it's the
engine of life in commerce whether it's
sales whether it's a politician whether
you're out of when you're got a hot dog
vendor you give me X I'll give you Y put
some mustard on the X please it's part
of job the part of Trump's job to shape
foreign policy based on what he feels
O'Neil's that he made right there hey
Greg yes this is like Senator Graham
yesterday saying it doesn't matter it
doesn't I'm not reading the trance I
didn't mention the strategy the
Democrats are strategy Republicans I
think the president could use some
warriors in the morning to wake up put
the war paint on and then fight this
impeachment the messaging the tactics
the strategy well one of the things
right now it's just leaked leaked leaked
leaked well one of the ways that they
could do that though is to have
effective cross-examination during the
public hearings okay because if you read
the transcripts it's like it's not that
great right from from that perspective
so they have to be super prepared I was
reminded by Karl Rove about Adam Schiff
back in 2008 he was the new chairman and
he was going to be investigating karl
rove and they were gonna get a scalp a
political scalp and Conyers was quoted
saying they were going to get his a SS
chin and brief didn't spell it out in a
political Scalia so they go to the
hearing and then Adam Schiff is actually
unprepared and like meeting from the
staff nodes and he just is not able to
actually bring a sale so now and
actually then that goes to the DOJ a DOJ
declined some prosecutors like this like
this is not this is a whole US attorney
thing now in 2019 in ten years of when
you didn't even have social media back
then
really you have them the Democrats are
planning to put on a show next Wednesday
with Adam Schiff we've been promised the
show I don't know if they can meet the
bar why is why shift the guy why is he
the one who's now in charge of this
whole thing why is a debate well they
had to do it in the dark and the
Intelligence Committee was the only
place they could pull that off and to
the people at home just want to
apologize you know this is a family show
and yeah it apologizes Dana that really
su CKS